mac et ma soeur il ya pierre et puis il
ya claude voici closer et le fils de
pierre kaffer s'affûte l'arbre et si
vous permettez père ma soeur je vais
poser une question à dix semaines de
repos leur jeu tourne le dos j'ai
retrouvé mon excuse je viens avec le
danseur je voudrais savoir et qu'elle
est en somme ce que pense ce que pensent
ils voulaient un fils dont il joue dans
une pièce qui écrit son père et quand le
père lui même joue dans la pièce est ce
qu'on n'a pas un trac on a déjà un track
sur scène certainement n'est ce pas le
cas c est ce qu on a pas encore plus le
trac le vestiaire que le trac n'est pas
le fait que je sois mon père le trac et
le fait que ce soit d'abord un grand
acteur low triangle amoureux d'autres
projets pas qu'il ait vue depuis hier
seuls les agréables avec son père c'est
après ces appareils spéciaux à paille à
la copie mais avant une loi sur
l'éthique avant il ya les conseillers à
la critique après les conseils avant
l'été ça qui est très agréable et puis
je ne vois pas deux heures par jour afin
de passage mais il ya quand même une
vidéo
justement on se dit c'est que l'île
secrète petite famille dans chaque ville
ah bon ce n'est pas grave on sait qu'il
est là et mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de jouer avec lui mais pas avec
lui ce qui m'amuse moi c'est de jouer
avec mais pas en tant que père en tant
que met en resterait là en tant qu' en
tant que grands patrons seraient
directement le maître de m
bien que le brasseur ce n'est pas vous
ne jouez pas pour la première fois au
théâtre plus si vous êtes déjà en
tournée et je pense qu'une tournée pour
un jeune nous a amené beaucoup de choses
bien sûr parce que dans chaque ville ils
ne sont absolument pas le même public il
veut leur donner la peine de travailler
en sont pas les mêmes mais c'est très
agréable on fait beaucoup de progrès du
progrès et puis y'a papa derrière qui
donnait comme l'écurie doit être dur
j'ai la passion non non non non il est
juste comme est fou
[Musique]